this section gives you an introduction
to cloud cloud computing enables you to
consume server infrastructure and
software platforms as a service over the
Internet
you don't have to buy and maintain
expensive Hardware in your data center
infrastructure includes raw resources
such as virtual machines networking
storage and more these resources are the
fundamental building blocks of cloud
computing when you consume
infrastructure as a service I as you
have greater control over the resources
but also greater management overhead for
example consider a virtual machine you
need to install upgrade and patch all
the software required to run your
application you can configure your
virtual machines to scale based on the
load on your application Google compute
engine networking and load balancers are
examples of I as platform as-a-service
paas provides a platform with managed
services where runtime environment and
network settings are pre-configured this
makes it easier for you to develop and
deploy your application Google App
Engine is an example of platform
as-a-service
Google App Engine comes pre-configured
with runtimes for Java Python node and
more software upgrades and patches are
automatically applied load balancing is
also pre-configured this enables the
developer to focus on the application
logic only instead of worrying about
infrastructure setup with software
as-a-service
SAS entire applications are managed and
made available in the cloud environment
Gmail is an example of a software as a
service this slide shows how you can use
Google cloud platform for application
data application logic and integration
with other Google services imagine an
online shopping website or a mobile app
the application needs to store and
retrieve different types of data as
follows the website or app displays
images of items such as shoes and
clothes these images can be stored in
Google Cloud storage high volume semi
structured data like gaming or streaming
data can be stored in no sequel
databases such as cloud datastore and
BigTable customer information can be
stored in a relational database such as
cloud sequel or cloud spanner
application logic can be deployed and
executed
on Google App Engine or google
kubernetes engine you can integrate with
other Google services such as Google
Maps and YouTube all of this
infrastructure can be started up in just
a few minutes without buying hardware or
installing software